hello everybody I just wanted to let you
guys know that I am on my way to
comic-con so I won't be around update
videos on a daily basis anymore I am
doing some pre-recorded stuff so that I
can have at least at least one game
video a day but that's always going to
be questionable because I'm not even
going to have a laptop when I'm out
there so if you guys can just be patient
with me I'm going to be updating with
photos on Facebook and I'm going to be
trying to do a video log every single
day with this my new love on my new but
it's my old Canon t3i it's a very good
quality camera I just never had a really
chance to use it but I'm going to bring
it so that I can take all the awesome
pictures I can at Comic Con so thank you
everyone for bearing with me through
this and I hope to give you some cool
stuff at Comic Con my brother is an
exhibitor there so I get to go backstage
and I don't have to do anything that he
has to do yes to sit in the booth all
day I get to go walking around the floor
so hopefully I'll meet in mcallen and
all the people from Hobbit but anyway
thanks everyone for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye